but the idea that in a community in a
conversation you could have a
non-aggression principle with another
human and that if you live like that
maybe it'll create a society where then
that starts to happen but it happens all
the time I've made optimistic statements
and I have to be careful because it
sounds too optimistic I say I remember
growing up as a kid in a depression in
World War II I was in uh grade school
high school College medical school
military and I said
there's hardly anybody that I met that I
thought was a real scoundrel
my neighbors had been easy to get along
with and and and and and and we happen
to be Believers so the people we
associated with in a spiritual way they
were never a threat to us so there were
a lot so my impression if it was my
narrow impression but people most people
would say yeah babe what a boring life
you had you know and and they wouldn't
accept this because life is much
different